i i want to jump back in time because we
have been taking for granted the
existence of
instant photography so we're looking
here this seems like a very odd image
of a famous italian sculpture of
david it's one of four it's taken in
florence and the image was taken
by an art historian by the name of
clarence
kennedy kennedy was a pioneering
figure in the photography of sculpture
this exhibit subtitle is the
intersection of art and technology
and i think it's um encapsulated best by
this early relationship between clarence
kennedy who came
to meet edwin land and george wainwright
kennedy met these two young
men and said look i am desperately
trying to aid my students
to better get a feeling
for sculpture and art but with sculpture
you know the essence is being able to
walk around them and
i wanted to find a new technology
uh using some sort of 3d imaging and
that conversation stimulated edwin land
tremendously and they suggested that he
try a technique of
taking a stereoscope set of photographs
one for your
left eye one for your right eye
projecting them carefully on a screen
and then they provided some polarizing
lenses and all of a sudden there was
a 3d image and
this technology was one that kennedy
and land continued to work on throughout
the 1930s and it led to
what you're seeing here in this image
it's called a vector graph
and that was a technique
of taking two negative images
dipping them into a
chemical solution for about four or five
minutes
and then pressing them together onto a
single base
but if you picked up the glasses that
are in that bucket
on to the left of the vector graph here
of david and put them on
all of a sudden you would now see the
sculpture
uh rendered in 3d
that was very magical and very exciting
even in the 60s and 70s and 80s people
felt that the vector graph
was the preeminent form of 3d
still imaging but i tell this story here
in some detail
because the famous origin story
of polaroid is that in december of 1943
land takes his daughter jennifer for a
walk
and they take some photographs and
jennifer
being three or four years old at the
time
says at the end of their walk why can't
i see the pictures now
and the reason he could think it was
possible was
all the work that he had done on the
vector graph technology
i think our origin story of polaroid
actually is predates jennifer's question
and goes back to that relationship with
clarence kennedy
you